It has been announced.
Kedushah u'Malchus
Holiness and Kingship.
What I'm going to do tonight
is to investigate malchut as a
political institution, monarchy as
a political institution, and also as
a metaphysical, transcendental idea.
And we'll try to define the attitude
of Yahadus toward both,
monarchy as a political institution
and as a great ethical idea.
Malchut
is inseparably linked up
with the human quest for
companionship
and coexistence.
Human sociability
was decreed by the
Almighty at the dawn of creation.
When He, in His inscrutable
wisdom, proclaimed that
man -- that loneliness is bad for
man's growth and development, "Lo tov
heyos ha'adam levado." And in order
to redeem Man or Adam from his tragic
solitude, He created Eve to join him.
Indeed, man, because of fear of
loneliness, has displayed a remarkable
talent for setting up social entities
and linking up his individual
solitary life with other beings.
Developing thus a complex
system of human relations.
Within this framework of social
cross-reference and relatedness, man
tries to protect himself from the
curse of being alone or being nobody.
Whether he's successful in his quest for
togetherness is a different problem, which
I'm not going to investigate tonight.
However,
within the group,
which was formed in order
to help man free himself
from his loneliness,
there is no ideal equality
even though the constitution or
the covenant by which the group was
established or formed might rest upon
democratic and liberal foundations.
No matter how progressive a
particular society is and however
sincerely it tries to do away with
discrimination and class distinction,
its members can never attain
equality in the personal sense.
The reason for inequality within society,
which we endure as long as many of you roam
upon the face of the globe, lies
in the paradoxical nature of man in
his individuality and uniqueness.
Inequality is perhaps the shibboleth of
man, the most characteristic trait of
him, the prime mark of distinction and
differentiation from the subhuman world.
As Chazal describes, our Sages, there are
no two men, two people alike, both as
the physical appearance, countenance
and as to their spiritual personality.
"K'shem sh'partzufeihem shonim
kach dei'oseihem shonos."
Hence, success -- successful man, strong
man emerges on the top, becomes king
Frustrated man, weak man,
meek man turns into a subject.
In other words, the fear of
aloneness or loneliness and
the quest for togetherness,
coexistence and cooperation has
precipitated the formation of power
structures and power relationships.
I am departing from my text.
Reading the Megillah last Purim,
I kept on thinking
I want to tell you; it did
not interfere with my kavanah.
I kept on thinking how little human power structures have changed.
Achashveirosh was a whimsical king,
a very irritable individual,
and quickly reached -- reaching decisions
on the spur of the moment.
Chazal, our
rabbis, said sarcastically of him, he
killed his beautiful queen, Vashti,
upon the advice of his best friend,
Memuchan, and later, he killed
his best friend upon the complaint
of his beautiful queen, Esther.
We enjoy, if we read properly, the
element of comedy which is employed by
the Megillah in portraying Achashveirosh.
However, if our thoughts should cross
what's been approximately 24 centuries
from Galut Bavel -- from the end of
Galut Bavel to 1969, we realize that
the same whimsicality or irritability
on the part of an individual might
result not merely in the execution
of one person, of the prime
minister, but in an ugly, bloody war.
Or, in a brutal invasion of a
country, like Czechoslovakia.
Even -- it might result even
in the destruction of mankind.
A capricious president, and
every human being is capricious.
In a moment of anger and wrath, he may
push the button and precipitate
a nuclear confrontation.
This depends just upon
the whim of one man.
Of an individual.
And the vainglorious president of France,
in a moment of annoyance and anger,
which we are less justified than that of Achashveirosh,
cut off the delivery of arms to a small nation,
which is fighting for its very existence.
I wonder indeed, how much has been
changed since the times of Achashveirosh.
Yahadut
has always been wary and very cautious of
political power structures and displayed
little tolerance for power concentrated
in the hands of an individual.
Well, of course, we had -- we were
compelled to reconcile ourselves with
these current realities that no matter how
impacted the government is and no matter
how undesirable the edifice of power on
the part of an individual, be elected
or be appointed, anarchy is still worse.
And therefore, we, I mean Yahadus, sanction
the idea of the political community.
The idea of a state, very reluctantly.
If I were
to characterize the attitude
of Yahadus to our political
community, I would categorize it
under the class of those precepts
of which our Rabbis, Chazal,
said, "Lo dibrah Torah
keneged yetzer ha'ra." Basically,
the institutions are imperfect, but imperfect man
must have imperfect institutions.
You cannot create a perfect
institution for imperfect man.
And you know very well,
you all probably say pereks
summer -- during the summer time.
I would even make a recommendation
this perek be studied in the yeshiva.
Now, students may riot and go on
strikes in order to enforce this.
Basically, Rabbi Chanina Sgan
HaKohanim meant to convey the same
thought when he made his famous
statement, "Hevei mispallel bishlomah
shel malchus," pray for the welfare
of government, "ish es rei'eihu chaim.”
They just have to think, is that while
government is never perfect,
but we -- we must have order
and -- a power structure because
without it, evil would triumph.
Let us just give our attention to the
precept of minuy melech because if we
want halachically to find out about the
attitude of Yahadus throughout government
in general and monarch in particular,
we must investigate halachically.
I mean, the mitzvah -- the precept of
minuy melech, the appointment of a king.
And by analyzing this precept, we'll arrive
at certain conclusions, which will be
very relevant to our subject matter.
The commandment concerning
the appointment of a king is not
without certain reservations.
I once heard from my father,
zichrono livrachah, that the
validity of the commandment is
dependent upon the fulfillment of
two prerequisites, of two conditions.
First, we are commanded or
duty-bound to appoint a king
if there is need for him.
If history, actually, dictates to us
and the -- this appointment and
requires the setting up of monarchy.
If, for instance,
that they felt the king is
indispensable for the defense
of the people and of their land,
then it's incumbent upon us to set up a
monarchy and appoint a king who should
fight our battles, who should defend
the land and defend the physical and
spiritual survival of the Jewish people.
The very Braisa -- the famous
Braisa in Sanhedrin that
has identified the verse of "Som tasim
alecha melech," thou shall appoint a
king as a positive precept, as binding,
speaks to other precepts, which
are tightly connected with that of the
appointment of a king, tasim li melech.
Namely, whoever knows it, the -- to defeat
Amalek, the destruction of Amalek and
the construction of the Beis Hamikdash,
which has to follow the appointment.
In other words, the duty of the
king is to provide the land and
the people this maximum security.
Otherwise, there would be no need
for the setting up of a monarchy.
Another situation may motivate or
prompt the selection of a king,
of a ruler, namely anarchy and
the breakdown of law and order.
The Bible in Shoftim, it means the
book preceding Samuel in which the
appointment of the king -- I mean, came up,
tells us and emphasizes
and reemphasizes, "Ba'yamim ha'hem," in
those days, "ein melech b'Yisrael," there
was no king in Israel, "ish
ha'yashar b'einav yaaseh," whatever a
person likes to do, he was free to do.
Why does the pasuk
emphasize it many times?
Because exactly this is -- this was
the determining factor which made the
appointment of the king mandatory.
If law and order had prevailed, I mean,
without a king, there would be no need for it.
The Rambam states in Hilchos Melachim -- Perek Dalet in Hilchos Melachim, Halachah 5,
"Sh'ein mamlichin melech
techilah ela laasos mishpat v'nilchem
milchamos. Sh'ne'emar 'U'shfatanu
malkeinu v'yatza lefaneinu v'nilcham
es milchamoseinu.'" The prime reason
for appointing a king was that he
implement the principles of justice
and wage war, as it is written, "And
that our king may judge us and go
out before us and fight our battles."
In a word,
the power structure is justified
if there is an external goal,
a transeunt goal which required
the setting up of such a structure.
Only the attainment of the goal
justifies the means.
There is purpose in this for
malchus, and the purpose not
in the power structure itself.
It's outside the power structure.
It is transeunt.
There is a teleology of kings, of royalty.
Each king has his own
to'eles, his own goal.
Each king pursues his own objective,
and the pursuit of the objective and
the effort on the part of the king to
realize the goal justifies kingdom,
human kingdom, which is always imperfect.
Each meluchah for each melech is charged
with a specific task according to Yahadus.
You don't appoint a melech just for
the sake of dominion or for the sake
of rule, of ruling or for the sake of
exercizing power or wielding authority.
Each melech, each king was
charged with a specific task.
Each one pursued a definitive objective,
whose implementation was the prime reason
for the ascendency of the king to malchut.
For instance, David's kingdom, the
kingdom of the great King David,
was wholly committed -- wholly
committed to the unification of the
loosely separated Tribes and the
complete conquest of Eretz Yisrael.
It's a timely subject.
And the security of the people.
If you study Shmuel well, you'll
find it between the lines.
And what does it tell
us, the malchus David?
It tells us of achdut Yisrael, kivush
ha'aretz and, of course, the safety
and the security of the people.
Solomon's rule was concerned
with the binyan Beis Hamikdash,
with the establishment of
the spiritual, sacred center,
the construction of the sanctuary.
Chizkiyah's rule, according to
our oral tradition, according to
Torah Sh'Baal Peh,
was dedicated
to the perpetuation of Torah.
According to Pirkei D’rabbi Nasan,
the founder of the Anshei Knesses HaGedolah
was not anyone but Chizkiyahu.
It means, in other words,
malchut is justified if there
is an assignment for malchut.
If there is no assignment,
there is no need for malchut.
The second prerequisite is
that the people request the
appointment of the king.
That the people recognize the need, that
the people state the need and ask Beis
Din or the prophet to appoint a king.
No monarch should be imposed upon the
people no matter how great the need it is.
In Devarim,
when the Torah
stated the precept of malchus,
it has qualified, that the
precept of malchut is linked up
with the request made by the people.
"V'amarta
asimu alai melech k'chol ha'goyim
asher sevivosai," and you make
the request or you make the demand
for the appointment of a king.
"Sim tasim alecha melech,"
then -- and of course,
people recognize the need, a great
assignment awaits the king,
but the people want him, then "Sim tasim
alecha melech," then Beis Din
is duty-bound to comply with
the request and appoint a king.
If the people do not utter
such a wish, Beis Din has no
right to establish a monarchy.
That the
suggestion of appointing a king
must come from the people and only then,
in compliance with their will, Beis Din
is obligated to select a monarch, is
stated almost unequivocally by the Rambam.
The Rambam's referring to a ma’amar of Rabbi Nehorai in Sanhedrin, which I
cannot analyze now, says as follows.
"Mei'achar sh'hakamas melech mitzvah
lamah li ratzah Hakadosh Baruch Hu
k'sh'shaalu melech mi'Shmuel lefi
sh'shaalu b'taromes v'lo shaalu
lekayem ha'mitzvah ela mipnei sh'katzu
bi'Shmuel HaNavi sh'ne'emar 'Lo is'cha
maasu ki osi.'" I'll translate it.
Seeing that the setting up the king
was a commandment, why did the Holy
One look with disfavor upon the request
made by the people of Samuel for a king?
Because they asked in a grievous spirit,
the request was prompted not by a desire
to fulfill a precept but by a desire to
rid themselves of Samuel the Prophet,
as it is written, "For they have not
rejected thee, but they have rejected Me."
I believe
that the question
must be asked immediately.
The question arises immediately,
and it's an obvious question.
Why should the way in which the
request was made affect the validity
or the binding character of the
precept of appointing the king?
Let us assume the request was not phrased in proper and intelligent language.
And that
the motive was it -- the wrong one.
There was still no reason for Shmuel
or Hakadosh Baruch Hu, kaviyachol,
to look with disfavor upon
the appointment of a king,
which constitutes a basic
precept, a mitzvah min haTorah.
What -- the wrong motivation
never nullifies the worth of the
act of a mitzvah deed, a gross
approach might not render
a deserving, noble act null and void.
You know, all remember the Rav -- the
Rav saying, "L'olam yaasok adam
b'Torah u'b'mitzvos sh'lo
lishmah u'mitoch sh'lo lishmah ba lishma”
And why did Hakadosh Baruch classify
their petition for a
king wrong and sinful, equating
-- equating it with rebellion
against G-d's authority,
"Lo os'cha maasu ki im osi."
Of course, the only logical conclusion
could be derived from Maimonides,
from this quotation from the Rambam.
That the request for a king is
of central significance since it is
the source of [inaudible].
Since it legitimizes the power
structure created by the appointment.
Since
the request is a condition, a sine qua non
for the fulfillment of the
implementation and the mitzvah of
minuy melech, of appointing a king.
Therefore, it is necessary that the
request be formulated in
compliance with the halachah.
That means the request is not
phrased in the proper and which -- and
is motivated by a wrong desire;
it fails to produce results.
And the appointment of a king is not mandatory.
And whenever
the appointment of a king is
not obligatory or mandatory,
it is sinful to appoint a king.
"Lo os'cha maasu ki osi."
The reason for the reluctance on the part
of Yahadus, to set up permanent power
structures -- because a monarch is a
permanent power structure -- such as
monarchy, is due to two motives.
First,
as the old saying goes,
power corrupts.
Abuse of power is inevitable.
The greatest of all rulers, of all
kings, the most ideal charismatic
leader is bound, willy-nilly, to step over
the boundary of legitimate authority
and engage in some kind of tyranny,
arbitrary decisions, unfair practices.
Power -- this is with the view of Yahadus
-- contrary to the popular opinion,
limits the freedom of the man of power.
The loss of freedom on the part of
the man of power is proportionate
to the amount of power with
which he was endowed and equipped.
The more authority that people bestow upon him,
the more of his
freedom is taken away.
The more the number of options which
he has at his disposal is limited.
Just now to quote one pasuk,
when Saul came back -- we just
read it last -- not last Shabbos,
but -- uh, the Shabbos Zachor.
When Saul came back from Amalek, bringing
along Agog and some cattle and some sheep.
And then Shmuel asked him why he violated
the word of G-d, why he didn't comply
with the instructions he gave him.
So Shaul had one excuse and this excuse
was very -- was fatal.
This excuse, I'm afraid,
sealed Shaul's destiny.
"Vayachmol Shaul v'ha'am al Agag v'al meitav ha'tzon."
Saul tries to justify his action
vis-á-vis Amalek when Samuel rebuked him,
for the people took of the spoil.
I didn't take; the
people took of the spoil.
And the word vayachmol
ha'am should be underlined.
I didn't take.
The people took of
the spoil, of the sheep, of the oxen.
I could not stop them.
I had to listen, too, and
reckon with the crowd.
A king cannot get along without a crowd.
The ruler must read the mind of
the gullible and very excitable crowd,
And when the ruler must
be concerned with the crowd
he cannot exercise -- he cannot exercise
legitimate authority or legitimate power.
But this reason is basically
of secondary nature.
This is not the main reason why
Yahadus was so reluctant and so
unwilling to accept power structures.
[missing audio]
Certainly, Yahadus says
the ruler is capable.
Otherwise, he wouldn't be a ruler.
Brilliant, G-d
blessed him with a sense of leadership
and an inspiring personality.
Certainly, those are -- who are
subordinated to him are down,
meek and in need of guidance.
So it's quite natural that one rules
and the other one is being ruled,
but Yahadus asks, but does
intellectual superiority
justify the exercise of power?
Do personal traits, no matter how
relevant, grant a person the right to
order, to instruct and to dominate?
And in general, Yahadus never
measured the worth of the human
personality by the yardstick of
his traits, his talents, never.
Yahadus many times, has repeated -- repeated
many times, a contrite heart is more
cherished by the Almighty than a keen
mind and a person modest and humble.
Because circumstances prevented him from
actualizing the human potential which G-d
implanted in him is more acceptable to
the Almighty than a person being proud
because he was lucky and circumstances
favored him and gave him the opportunity
to achieve fame and take advantage of
every talent G-d has equipped him with.
Moreover, man is not being invited
to share the attribute of meluchah
and memshalah, we say,
"Ha'meluchah v'ha'memshalah
l'chai olamim," kingdom and might
belongs exclusively to the eternal.
True, many divine potencies
are accessible to man.
The Almighty asks of man quite often
to join him and, paradoxically, to
be like Him, "V'halachta bi'drachav."
Moreover, it is G-d's will that man
imitate him, that man follow in his
ways, that man attempt to be divine,
to participate in the infinite moral
acting on the part of the Almighty.
"V'halachata bi'drachav," more pungent
is the expression "V'anveihu," Ani V’Hu
I like Him, "mah hu chanun,"
He is merciful, I want to be
merciful as well, "mah hu rachum,"
He's charitable and kind, I
want to be charitable and kind
as well, and so forth, so on.
Yet, power is an exception to the rule
of "V'halachta bi'drachav." You don't say
He is mighty; I also want to be mighty.
Power is an exclusive divine
potency to which man has no access.
Melech Elyon
dislikes very much -- Melech Evyon.
If the latter begins to
take himself seriously.
The quest for power, basically,
precipitated the first
scene on the part of man.
The serpent took advantage of human -- of
the human urge to rule, to dominate,
to be mighty, to emerge victorious from
every engagement, to legislate his own
laws, et cetera, and persuaded Eve to sin
by telling her that through eating
from the Tree of Knowledge,
she will realize her ambition.
She'll become powerful.
"Vi'heyisem kei'Elokim yodei tov va'ra."
And Yahadus was not only wary and
cautious with regard to the political
community, the so-called executive
branch of power and the legislative
branch of power, but also very
cautious with reference to the judicial
community, for the judicial branch of
government.
And again, Yahadus has always
been confronted with an antinomy,
inquiring into the very core of
power exercise and power structure,
including the judicial power structure.
On one hand, Yahadus was convinced that
due to the -- to the human situation
or to a human situation, when one
cannot dispense with those structures.
On the other hand, it
is consistently argued that
man is not entitled to sit in
judgment over his fellow man.
Only G-d has the right to judge
people, "Elokim nitzav ba'adas
Kel b'kerev Elokim yishpot."
That's why Yahadus is complicated.
It's very much -- sometimes we -- we marvel at the difficulties and
complexities -- complexities that Yahadus
has introduced in the judicial process.
It has almost eliminated not only bodily
punishment,
we have many chayevey misa, yes.
But we have
executed very few in our history.
We have many chayvu malkus, but we
have implemented this punish -- this
penalty very rarely -- very rarely.
It has eliminated not only
bodily punishment but also
monetary fines like k'nas.
Nowadays, you know, "ein anu danim
dinei k'nasos," because we lack
semichah, we -- we lack the authority.
Even as regards trivial, everyday
litigation, in civil matters,
Yahadus has almost, with fear and foreboding,
warned the dayan, the justice who is
authorized to resolve the controversy
that he's engaged in something awesome
and dreadful and that in case he should
err, or even faulter, in the execution
of justice, his sin will be unpardonable.
"L'olam yireh dayan atzmo k'ilu cherev
munachas lo al tzavaro v'Gehinnom
pesuchah lo mitach'tav v'yeida es mi hu dan,
v'lifnei mi hu dan" -- I'm reading
Maimon -- the Rambam -- "u'mi asid
l'hipara mimenu im nata mi'kav ha'emes
sh'ne'emar 'Elokim nitzav baadas Kel,'
v'omer 'Re'u mah atem osim ki lo l'adam
tishpetu ki la'Adoshem.'" At all times,
the judge should think of himself as
if a sword were suspended over his
head and Gehinnom gaping under him.
He should know who he is judging -- whom
he's judging and before whom he's judging.
And who will
call him to account if he deviates.
Comes the line of truth, as it is written,
"G-d standed [sic] in the congregation
of G-d, in the midst of the judges."
And it's also written, "Consider what
you do, for you are judged not for
man, but for the law," Chronicles 19:6.
This is more or less the
general attitude of Yahadus.
Of course, I could quote many sources
substantiating and confirming,
I mean, my interpretation,
but there's no need for it.
But malchus signifies not only a
complete power structure, a political
institution or a political community,
a kingdom, government, state, but
also a great metaphysical idea.
Malchus, in its metaphysical context,
turns into a glorious vision which
the covenantal community has beheld
and has been fascinated with since
the dawn of its millennial history.
Malchus as a metaphysical idea, turns into
a great ethical norm, which is how
to achieve the ultimate objective in Yahadus.
Within the metaphysical frame of reference,
malchus is not a prerogative of an individual, of a single person,
or a clan or a dynasty.
Within the metaphysical frame of reference,
malchus has been bestowed upon men in general.
On that mysterious Friday, when God
fashioned him out of dust and made him
an individual being, unique and singular,
who cannot be replaced, for whom there
is no substitute.
Later man lost malchus, according
to Chazal, when he sinned.
And God wants His covenantal
community, His people, to restore the
quality of malchus to its members.
So basically, the potential of malchus
has been implanted in every Jew.
The question is how to implement
it, how to realize it.
Of course, in order to realize it, we
have got to understand what it is, what
it stands for, what it requires of man.
How does malchus, as a moral
metaphysical idea, express itself?
How does it express itself?
Again, we must consult the Halachah.
We stated, and we also tried
to prove, that malchus as a
legitimate political structure
requires an objective,
a telos, an assignment.
Whenever there is urgent need for the
setting up of such an institution,
it's incumbent upon us to implement
the precepts of appointing a king.
In other words, malchus is significant
whenever history burdens this
institution with a specific mission.
As I said before, the power structure
is of a teleological nature.
In a word, malchus
equals
assignment awareness.
The awareness that one has an assignment
to implement and to carry out.
The equation is of course, like
many other equations, reversible.
We may say, therefore, an
assignment awareness equals malchus.
Who is king?
Who is king in the metaphysical sense?
Whoever felt -- feels committed.
Whoever feels committed to the
achievement of a great goal;
to the realization of an objective.
Who is a king?
Whoever carries a load.
It's very strange that in
Hebrew, a load, masa, is
of course, to be understood in a physical
sense and also in a spiritual sense.
Masa is also prophecy.
The prophet is loaded, or burdened.
He's dedicated, he's committed.
He's not free.
Malchus takes away freedom, I
told you before, but not -- but
by taking away freedom, one's
personality is being enhanced.
Who is king?
Whoever is burdened with a task.
Whoever has a concern for
something, and he is ready, I
mean, to implement his assignment.
And here, I said it many times.
I don't know when I last
spoke to you about it.
Here Yahadus comes in with
its doctrine of assignment.
It's a very important doctrine.
Not only important theoretically or
philosophically; it's important
in practical terms, too.
Each man was created in order
to carry out a certain task.
He was created at a certain time,
in a certain place, in a certain society,
he was born into a certain family.
Because all those circumstances will
make it possible for him to implement
his tasks.
The fact that I wasn't born a
century ago is because a century
ago, I couldn't carry out my task.
I can't -- that's what they say,
Elokai, ad shelo notzarti,
I wasn't created 100 years ago,
I wasn't created 200 years ago, I
was not created 300 years ago.
I was not created during -- in the course
of countless centuries, in many millennia.
You know why?
Eineni kedai,
because I was not worthy of being
created, because I had no assignment.
Had I been created, I wouldn't
have had an assignment.
Each man was created in order
to carry out a certain task.
Each individual was entrusted with
a specific assignment which he must
implement, no matter how difficult,
and no matter how embarrassing
sometimes the implementation is.
It is not just incidental that in Hebrew,
we do not distinguish between wage
and reward, between contracted and
non-contracted compensation, the way
we do -- we do in other languages.
We say in English a wage means
that you pay a laborer or a
hireling whom you contracted to
perform a certain task for you.
When you say a reward, it
means a gratuitous award.
You give him because he is meritorious,
but there is no obligation and no
commitment on your part to reward him.
If you do reward him, it's a
voluntary act on your part.
It's generosity.
Yahadus has no two words.
The Biblical and Talmudic Hebrew, in
the Biblical and -- and the Talmudic
Hebrew, the noun sachar has the
connotation of reward, as well as of wage.
The noun sachar has a dual
connotation, a wage and reward.
Yahadus apparently, has apparently
considered the good bestowed upon man
for a meritorious life as an earned
wage, not as a gratuitous reward.
Because man, according to Yahadus, is
under contractual obligation to his
employer, who happens to be the Almighty.
He is actually a hireling who was
contracted to perform a specific task
and who, upon completing his assignment,
may lay claim to well-earned compensation.
And it is not -- and there is
nothing new in what I am saying.
It's a verse in Iyov.
"Im charutzim yamav mispar
chodashav itach chukav asis -- asisa
v'lo ya'avor. She'ei mei'alav
v'yechdal ad yirtzeh k'sachir."
Seeing his days are determined, the number
of his months are with Thee, and Thou has
appointed his bounds that he cannot pass.
If you look away from him that
he may rest until he shall
accomplish, as a hireling, his day.
The life of man is like a day which
has been completed by the hireling.
Man is a sachir.
Of course, you know very well that the
assignment theory, doctrine was -- has
been spelled out in unmistakable
terms, unequivocal and unmistakable
terms in what book in Tanach?
In what book in Tanach?
The assignment doctrine, man is
created and charged with an assignment.
And all he has to do is
to carry out his task.
In what book?
What book?
Yonah.
Yes, of course.
Yonah, yes.
But Yonah you speak of a prophet, nevu'ah.
Of course, nevu'ah is also an assignment.
It's a load placed upon the prophecy.
It's a burden.
But I believe there’s another
book, we just read it.
In the Megillah.
Isn’t it?
And I believe that the assignment doctrine
is a focal theme of the Megillah.
Let me read a pasuk, it's one pasuk.
"Al tedami v'nafsheich l'himaleit
beis hamelech mikol hayehudim.
im hachareish tacharishi ba'eis hazos
revach v'hatzalah ya'amod layehudim
mimakom acher v'as u'veis avich toveidu,
u'mi yodei'a," I'm emphasizing the words,
"im l'eis kazos higa'at lamalchus."
Nu, would someone volunteer
to translate these words?
Think not with thyself that
thou shall escape in the king's
house more than all the Jews.
If thou altogether holdeth thy peace
at this time, then the relief and
deliverance will arise to the Jews
from another place, but thou and thy
fathers' house will perish, and who
knows whether thou art not come to
royal estate for such a time as this?
Basically, what Mordechai said is simply
that there is an assignment for each individual.
And he reminded Esther of
the assignment which was entrusted to her
and of the summons -- of the historical
summons which she has to answer.
And about -- and of the
historical challenge which
she has to accept and to meet.
Basically, Mordechai analyzed
here and formulated three ideas
within the assignment doctrine.
The assignment doctrine consists
of three basic thoughts.
First, each
individual is assigned a task which he
must implement.
The assignment never
transcends one's ability.
The individual is never required
of -- to do something that is
above and beyond his reach.
And as far as Esther is concerned,
Mordechai said, Esther was favored by
the Almighty with beauty and irresistible
charm and at the same time, charged
with the mission of saving her people.
It is strange.
The mission of saving the people
who was placed squarely upon
the athletic, strong shoulders of David
and his commander-in chief Yoav, and now,
the same mission, was placed upon
the frail, upon the frail shoulders
of a delicate and lonely woman who's
-- who's -- who continuously lived in
the shadow of rejection and death.
She was burdened with the same mission
with which the kingdom of David
was charged, to save the people
and to defeat a formidable
enemy and to protect the Jewish
community from annihilation.
And if you will ask me now, what
is our assignment in these days?
What is the assignment of
the Jewish community in 1969?
Of course, it’s very hard to guess.
Each one has an assignment which is
known only to God Almighty, but sometimes
we may -- we may find out, we may
explore -- just, I mean, a bit and, and,
and somehow come across the assignment.
What is the assignment that -- with
which we are charged now,
everyone, every Jew, man or woman?
I believe the assignment is a double one.
First, to safeguard and protect
the physical -- the Jew physically.
To defend the physical
survival of the Jew.
First of all, in Eretz Yisrael it is
a daily problem because it's not a
question in Eretz Yisrael about a state.
This is already a minor problem.
This is already a secondary
or a thirdly problem.
The Arabs don't want to annihilate
the state -- only the state.
They simply want to annihilate the
Jewish community as such, because
we live in a post-Hitlerian -- in a
post-Hitlerian era, and the Jewish
enemy is very sophisticated now.
In the Middle Ages and in modern times,
the enemy of the Jew tried to -- tried
to persecute the Jew, to legislate
restrictive laws, to make his life
hard, to lock him up in the ghetto, to
take away his franchise, his liberties.
But now these enemies of the Jews are sophisticated.
He's a liberal.
He's a democrat now.
All he wants is to kill the Jew.
And what do you think?
If the Arabs had
won -- rachmana litzlan, if the
Arabs had won the war in 1967,
what would have happened
to the Jewish population?
It is entrusted not only to the
Israelis, but us as well.
And I don't mean as far as extending
help to Israel is concerned, but
I mean even in the diaspora we
should be on alert -- on alert.
Look out for any manifestation of
anti-Semitism, for any leaflet,
for any song, for any poem on the radio.
And let not liberals or intellectuals tell
you it is irrelevant, it is kid stuff.
I lived in Germany during the
ascendancy of Hitler to power,
and I heard the same song in Germany.
When the Hitler brigade used to
march through Kurfürstendamm and
sing the, the Horst Wessel song,
so the intellectuals laughed.
They joked.
But apparently, kid stuff has
resulted in the crematoria at Majdanek
and the gas chambers of Majdanek.
Look out for it!
And no politician, mayor or
governor or, or, or congressman or
senator should be tolerated if he
tolerates anti-Semitic literature
or statements of city
employees or city appointees.
Secondly, this is the assignment
which resembles the tasks with
which Mordechai challenged Esther.
Second.
This is just as important
as the first assignment.
We must defend the spiritual
identity of the Jew in the diaspora,
and as well as in Eretz Yisrael.
Against assimilationism,
against disintegration, and also
against apostasy, against shmad.
Don't dismiss this problem.
Now this is the first -- the first
element of the doctrine of,
assignment which Mordechai formulated,
is simply that each individual is
entrusted with a task and he -- which
he must implement at all costs.
Second -- what is, what
is the second part?
The second element of the doctrine
of assignment the way Mordechai
has defined and formulated it,
in case of human failure and human
betrayals and human indifference,
God's will will be done anyway.
The assignment will be carried
out, if not by the -- by the
individual, by someone else.
"Im hachareish tacharishi ba'eis
hazos revach v'hatzalah ya'amod
layehudim mimakom acher."
And third, the third element, the
individual who did not answer the
call of history and did not respond
to the challenge and did not carry
out his assignment is a traitor and
his sin is unpardonable.
Now, malchut, in order to be a melech,
to acquire not a kingdom – there is no
need to acquire a kingdom – but kingship.
To acquire not a meluchah, but malchut.
One must be aware
of the assignment.
That man is a committed
being, not a free being.
But malchus contains another dimension.
Namely that of an open existence.
I want to -- I want to explain.
Let me explain -- explain it
by introducing a Kabbalistic equation.
To the ubiquitous
presence of God within the world.
Not outside, but in this world.
Within the natural cosmic order or drama.
When we mention or we say
or pronounce the name of the Holy One –
Kel.
We refer to His remoteness, transcendence
beyond the fringes and the outskirts of
the universe.
And above the here-and-now reality.
However, when we say Shechina,
we address ourselves to God who
has never been distant from us,
who stands next to us, or to me,
who trails behind me and
walks in front of me.
Adoshem tzili al yad yemini.
To God with whom I converse, to
whom I pray and cling in times of
distress, to whom I sing a hymn of
praise when destiny is good to me.
In whom I confined -- I confide,
and  in whom I find comfort and solace
and peace of mind and serenity.
In short, Shechinah denotes an open,
communicative, divine presence
in nearness which stands against
separating creator from creature.
You know very well that Shechinah
is from the verb shachein.
And what does shachein mean?
To abide, to be present, to reside.
You know what shachein in Hebrew means?
A neighbor.
However,
the term Shechinah signifies not only
imminence and proximity in a communicative
sense, but also in a sympathetic sense.
Shechinah is the mother,
matronita, who is kind and understanding
and displays unlimited tolerance and
patience for her imperfect child.
And that imperfect child happens to be
man himself, in all his majesty and glory.
Forgiving his shortcomings, overlooking
his errors, and not minding his
nonsensical insolence and impudence.
Patiently, she waits for her
child to come back, to regret, to
confess, and to amend his ways.
She never deserts her child.
She never deserts a sinner.
Ani Adoshem hashochein
itam b'toch tum'osam.
I am God who resides in the
midst of their defiled existence.
In a word, Shechinah
is not -- Shechinah not
only communicates to man,
but also has compassion for man.
She shares his troubles, his cares,
his tragic experiences and failures
for which -- for which he
himself is responsible.
B'zman she'adam mitz'ta'er, the
Mishnah says in Sanhedrin, Shechinah
mah omeres, what does Shechinah
say, kalani mizero'i, kalani meiroshi.
I have pain in my arm,
I have pain in my head.
The same is true -- applies to the
individuals who want to achieve kingship.
because al pi kabbalah, according to
kabbalah, Shechinah equals malchus
– Shechinah is identical with malchus.
So what is malchus?
What is kingship?
How does one achieve
kingship, how does one
realize the idea of kingship?
By
having an open existence.
An open existence is a royal existence.
The king resides in the
midst of the people.
It's quite interesting
that a king in Israel was always close
to his subjects, accessible to them.
Read the Tanach, leader of
a wood chopper, water drawer,
vagabond, stranger, and old-timer,
senior and babe, thief and merchant,
everybody and everyone could
approach the king to complain for him
and to demand justice and to ask for help.
I'll just quote the pesukim.
Then came there -- it means
before the King Solomon -- two
women that were harlots,
unto the king and stood before him.
Who admitted them?
What is the answer?
There was no need for anybody
to admit them; they just
opened the door and walked in.
And as the king of Israel was passing
by upon the wall, there cried a woman
unto him saying help, my lord, my king.
Such absurd rules as -- about
which we read in the Megillah last
week, "ki chol ish v'ishah
asher yavo… el hechatzer hapnimis
asher lo yikarei achas daso l'hamis
levad mei'asher yoshit lo hamelech
es sharvit hazahav v'chayah."
That appearing before the king in
the inner courtyard without the
invitation of the king, there is only
one outcome, that he is put to death.
Such absurd rules have never existed
in the annals of Yahadut.
Everybody could knock on the door
of the king and come in, because
everybody can knock on the door of
the king, melech malchei hamelachim
and come in.
And in the accessibility of
the melech malchei hamelachim
lies the mystery of tefillah.
What is tefillah?
I can open the door and walk in
and appear -- and appear before the
throne of the Almighty and complain
and to cry and to thank,
and to demand and to request and to beg.
In a word, man who aspires
to kingship must open up
his existence, be communicative,
accessible, and be capable of coordinating
his basic needs with the needs of others.
When I say
an open existence, please
don't make any mistake.
I do not mean the cultivation of
sociability or gregariousness.
An open existence can be achieved
by the introvert or even the
introspective person nowadays.
Sociability, gregariousness are
not necessarily the traits
of an -- of existential openness.
What I
want to express with
this term is that man,
while living, working, suffering,
rejoicing, and moving along an endless
trail of his own which no one else
will ever cross, must always remember
that in spite of the fact that he
is a singular being, he is not the
only one and he's not a single being.
That God's concern encompasses
not only him, but countless
individuals like him who also
wander, each one along his own trail.
While malchus in general historical terms
precipitates separation of the king from the people,
his elevation over them and his existential exquisiteness,
by moving the king from the periphery,
from the crowd, to the center,
malchus in Yahadus according to our view
means integration
of the individual in the community
and existential all-inclusiveness and openness.
And let me tell you something.
It is not just pseudo-philosophy, what I tell you now.
It's more than that.
It’s of practical relevance.
Malchus within Yahadus means
the acceptance of the Klal Yisrael.
Good or bad.
Whether the Klal Yisrael consists
of sinners or saints.
We must accept the Klal Yisrael as it is,
and open our existence to the Klal Yisrael.
Any acts of dividing the Klal Yisrael,
any acts of separating people,
of creating a sectarian philosophy.
Any acts which is out to
promote and cultivate isolationism
and modern religious egocentrism
and self-righteousness
violates the principle of existential openness.
Who is a king?
A Jew is, who opens himself up.
He opens himself up to the Klal Yisrael.
And embraces the entire Klal Yisrael,
without excluding anybody.
The king's existential openness
is both of a communicative
as well as a sympathetic nature.
That's what I call communicative
existential openness,
when I remember that God's concern
embraces everybody.
But there is also, I mean, the
Shechinah as I said before,
not only communicates with man,
but suffers with him,
has compassion with him,
participates in his struggles.
So must the king's existence
be an open one not only in a
communicative sense,
but also in a sympathetic sense.
Rambam, speaking of
the king, uses a very strange
term -- not term, phrase.
"Mipnei shelibo lev kol
Yisrael." The heart of the king
is the heart of the kehila.
Malchus requires of man not only to be
aware of the existence of others,
but to feel -- but also to feel, to
experience their existence, as if it
were his own.
In other words, malchus requires
of man to join and sit together to
share his ambitions, dreams, and
particularly pain and suffering.
As long as I am
just cognizant of the existence of fellow
man, I would just categorize as rei'a.
You know what rei'a in Hebrew is?
Ki savo b'kerem rei'acha, ki
yigaf shor ish et shor rei'eihu.
Rei'a.
A comrade, an acquaintance, a neighbor,
sometimes a good one, sometimes a bad one.
Because the pasuk also says, ki
yakum ish al rei'eihu l'hargo b’arma.
If one should conspire to
kill his rei'a, his comrade.
He was a rei'a yesterday, yesteryear,
but now he is an enemy of mine.
Of course, I mean, in the
political community, I mean,
these changes take place.
I am just a rei'a, a neighbor.
The very instant, the very instant
-- the very instant I begin to
perceive -- not to know him but to
perceive him, to feel his existence,
experience his joys and frustrations,
agony, and hope,
I turn from rei'a into what?
Into what?
Into a brother.
Into ach.
This higher degree of coexistence, of
interrelatedness and, and companionship.
A brother,
what is a brother -- what
does brotherliness mean?
Existential unity.
One destiny.
One life.
One memory.
The precept of tzedakah
in Yahadus, of tzedakah and chessed, is
nurtured by the doctrine of sympathetic
-- sympathetic openness, of a sympathetic
open existence, or by brotherliness.
While speaking of charity and of
tzedakah, the Torah constantly employs,
without a single exception, constantly
employs the term ach, not rei'acha.
Ki yamuch achicha, ki yihiyeh
becha evyon mei'achad achicha.
Never has the Torah used the term rei'a.
Because rei'a might
-- you see, when the Torah speaks about
civil law, not to inflict harm on
someone, so it employs the term rei'a.
The same thing, my neighbor imposes
a duty, an obligation upon me.
I should respect his property, respect
his rights, and not inflict -- and
I must not inflict any harm
or damages -- or damage on him.
But this does not entitle the
rei'a to my support, that I should
share his troubles and be
helpful to him in times of need.
For that, the bond of rei'a is too weak.
You need a stronger bond,
that of ach, brother.
Maimonides, the Rambam, emphasized
the element of brotherliness
in, in conjunction with
the tzedakah.
One is obligated to help and to share with
the unfortunate one his woes and misery.
Because in tzedakah is not -- I
wanted to say, halachically,
tzedakah does not consist exclusively
of extending material help.
Sharing experiences, comfort, and,
and, and displaying sympathy and
compassion is a part of mitzvas tzedakah.
At times, it's more important than the
material help I'd extend to someone else.
At this juncture, a new concept
of power in Yahadus emerges.
We said before that the Torah was
very reluctant about sanctioning
power and promoting unlimited power.
It has just reconciled itself with
historical realities and nothing
else, but the Torah considers
power structures as imperfect.
But there is one power structure,
whether they may call -- we should
call it a power structure or not is
a different problem, but there is one
form of power of authority which the
Torah sanctions -- not only sanctions,
recommended and stressed
the importance of it.
There is one form of power
or authority which Yahadus
sanctioned wholeheartedly; mainly,
the authority exercised by
the teacher over his pupil.
The relationship between a rav and talmid,
between teacher and pupil, or may I
use another word, master and disciple.
The commanding influence of the
master over his disciples was
accepted by the Torah without any
qualifications or reservations.
In fact, the
spiritual authority is quite
often superior to political power.
More, it endures longer and
is almost all inclusive.
At times, spiritual authority
borders on the ultimate
and blind obedience.
Of course, I may make
the following remark.
This kind of power may
sometimes be misused and abused
by unscrupulous teachers.
Remember that.
And please don't suspect me if I
am preaching a -- a doctrine which
is convenient for me, which is
relevant to me, but this is -- this
is a central thought in Yahadus,
but, of course, the
teacher should be ideal.
The impact for instance, that the Baal
Shem Tov, had upon his disciples and
through them and the likes of hundreds
of thousands of Jews throughout two
centuries, can hardly be matched
by any ruler in the history
of the political community.
The same is true -- I mean, I
could mention many names, but the
same is true as the Gaon of Vilna.
The latter, I mentioned him because the
latter was a contemporary of Napoleon
-- he was just a bit older
who has been considered
as the prototype of the man
of the man of power.
as the prototype of the charismatic leader.
Warlord, legislator, and king.
Yet the -- yet the Gaon’s posthumous
authority outlives the death
of Napoleon and many others.
While Yahadus has been perturbed
about political power,
it tried to limit its exercise
as much as possible.
it did encourage a disciple to give
boundless respect to his teacher,
the talmid to the rav, to listen
to him and to fulfill his wishes.
And do I have to quote many
maamerei Chazal in -- in order
to substantiate that statement.
What do you say?
Could someone suggest just one
maamar Chazal, which will suffice
-- I mean, to -- to clinch
it -- to clinch it up?
"'Es Adoshem Elokecha tira' l'rabos
talmidei chachamim," and take yourselves
talmidei chachamim is to be interpreted
in terms of teachers, rabbi muvhak,
his grand-teacher, who trained you.
"Thou shall fear the Lord, thy God,"
this precept also includes the norm to
fear and respect scholars and teachers.
God is not ready to share His
authority and power with the king,
with the political community.
However, He is willing to share his
authority, His power, with the spiritual
community and with the teachers.
Why?
His hameluchah v'hamemshalah is
jealous of being guarded for God.
Why did Yahadus surrender to the teacher?
Yahadus refused to surrender to the king,
To the greatest of all kings, but did
surrender to the teacher,
to the rav.
Two reasons lie at the root of the
Judaic glorification and idealization
of the teacher, of the rav.
First, the authority of the
rav is not imposed upon the pupil.
No political instrument is used.
No coercive action is undertaken
to force the authority of
the rav upon the pupil.
The talmid of
his own free will yields to
the authority of the teacher.
He joyfully so -- joyfully submits
to his -- to his way of thinking.
At times, the teacher felt -- feels
embarrassed by the deference of the
pupil and by the bad habit --
to imitate the teacher.
At times, while political authority
of the king is nurtured by fear,
spiritual authority of the rav is
rooted in deep affection and respect.
Teacher, yes.
Yes, teacher is a master like the king is
a master, but the mastery of the teacher
does not result in slavery of
the pupil, but in his freedom.
The mastery of the king principates
slavery of the subjects.
Second reason why Yahadus has
glorified the teacher, idealized him.
And God is ready to share His
authority, His power with the teacher.
Authority and ownership
are identical concepts.
Authority is vested in whom?
In the owner who can dispose
or reuse his property in any
arbitrary fashion or manner.
I can break it up, I can destroy it, I
can give it away, I can take it away.
I have full, unlimited
authority over my property.
The head of the political community
I mean, excuse me.
Yahadus has denied authority to the
head of the political community for
a simple reason: because the head,
the king, does not own his subjects.
They don't belong to him.
They are his equals in
the eyes of Yahadus,
whom he has no right to rule.
God's authority is boundless.
You know why?
Because He's the maker of all things.
That's why He rules all things.
He's the king of unlimited authority
because He is the creator of -- of many
things, of the endless and vast universe.
"La'Adoshem"...
However, in a very strange way, has
always looked upon the teacher, if
not as upon a creator ex nihilo -- a
human being cannot create ex
nihilo -- then, at least, as upon a
fashioner -- a fashioner,
an artisan,
who takes premortal matter and
impresses upon it a form upon it.
Shape something amorphous into
something beautiful and fascinating.
And Yahadus has said
that the subject does not belong to
the king, but a pupil belongs to the teacher.
because the latter trained him
and enlightened him,
sensitized his heart
and molded his personality and
brought out his noblest and
the finest and the best in him.
And I want to add something:
The authority of the parent
according to Yahadus is
rooted in the authority of the teacher.
The parent is a teacher and perhaps the
most outstanding teacher of the child,
and that's why the child is [inaudible]
as partners who share the -- who share
the child -- and they share the child,
Hakadosh Baruch Hu, aviv, v’imo.
Yahadus considers talmud Torah or
limud Torah, teaching the Torah,
as creative work and as a reflex of
the infinite practice of creation
initiated by God
at the dawn of history.
And which has never come to a close.
God summons man to participate in this
great, wonderous drama of creation.
The teacher, the rav, answers
the call and joins the Creator.
Hence, he has a share in the student.
He owns him because he's responsible
for everything the student stands for.
And it's self-evident that
with ownership comes authority.
"V'es ha'nefesh asher asu b'Charan."
I don't have to reach out too far.
The souls which
they made in Charan.
How can you make a soul?
Only God can make a soul.
How could Abraham and Sarah
make souls -- create souls?
So Chazal say, "Melamed sh'Avraham
m'gayer es ha'anashim," Abraham
made these souls because -- because he
enlightened and taught them, "v'Sarah
es ha'nashim," likewise did Sarah
participate in the creative gesture?
Because she taught and enlightened people.
As a matter of fact, the creative,
didactic gesture -- the educational
gesture of teaching consists in
the opening up of one's existence.
It's not a mechanical practice.
It's more a metaphysical practice.
And I've been a teacher for
many, many years, 28 years.
Bad teacher, a good teacher,
but I've been -- I mean, I try hard.
It's very hard to get rid of me
when I come into the classes.
It does not consist in mechanical
testing on -- of information
because if he’s just one who
passes down information,
hands down information,
He's a very poor teacher.
I wouldn't hire him as a rosh yeshiva
if I were the boss.
It consists in the metaphysical,
or I would say, metapersonal
process or gesture of opening up
one's existence, of letting the
student share in the great spiritual
treasures stored up in the depths
and the recesses of the teacher.
One cannot teach unless he tears down
old barriers, separating individual
-- individuals from each other, unless he
is ready to establish an
existential community
[no audio]
its full realization.
No wonder that Chazal spoke of Rabbanan,
"Man malchi," who are the king?
Rabbanan, not because
they were very wealthy.
We know chachmei Chazal lived
in poverty, in which, I mean,
of scholars found themselves.
Malki Rabbanan because
they [inaudible] a -- exercise authority
-- authority which is nurtured by love.
As a matter of fact, let me come back
to the -- to the political community.
The glorious -- tradition
of Malchus Beis David,
which is supposed to find its
culmination in the King Messiah.
Of course, it's a principal
tenant of our credo.
Rests not upon the king at the
head of a political community but
upon the king-teacher doctrine.
Who is the Messiah?
A politically powerful monarch?
Certainly not.
Who is he?
A -- one whose authority
was established by force?
Certainly not -- no.
Who is he?
The Messiah is a great, wonderous
teacher, prophet, who will
teach, instruct, enlighten, and
by so doing, redeem the world.
I don't have to quote the Rambam for that.
The Rambam is very explicit.
"Mipnei sh'oso ha'melech" -- the Rambam
says in Hilchos Teshuvah -- "sh'yaamod
mi'zera David baal chochmah yihyeh yeser
mi'Shlomo v'navi gadol hu karov l'Moshe
Rabbeinu u'lefikach yelamed es kol
ha'am v'yoreh derech Adoshem v'yavo'u
kol ha'goyim l'shamo" -- [inaudible]
to Solomon and will be a great
prophet of the Jewish people and
instruct them in the ways of God and
all nations will come to hear him.
As it is said, "And at the end of
days, it shall come to pass that
the mount of the Lord's house
shall be established -- established
at the top of the mountain. And
we taught of His ways and we'll -- and
we'll walk in His path."
The Rambam
couldn't have said it in more explicit
terms that the idea of malchus is the
synthesis or the merger of king/teacher.
And please, those who take philosophy
and take Plato, please don't confuse this
theory with Plato's theory of the state.
There is no -- there's
no common denominator.
Malchut -- I repeat, Malchut
achieves its complete realization
in the teacher-king union.
Not teachers' union but teach-king union.
Let me just give you one example.
We have a rule in Talmud, "Moshe Rabbeinu
melech hayah," Moshe Rabbeinu was a king,
halachically.
There is a pasuk, basically.
Of course, the pasuk could be interpreted
in two ways, but a Midrash interpreted
the pasuk with reference to Moshe.
"Va'yehi bi'Yeshurun melech b'hisasef
roshei am yachad Shivtei Yisrael." Why
was Moses a king?
And if Moses was a king, he was the
greatest of all kings in our history.
Why was he a king?
Because he was the greatest
teacher the -- the Jews ever had
and the greatest teacher is ipso facto
the greatest king.
As a matter of fact, when the Gemara
in Brachos -- portrays David as
a rosh yeshiva.
David is off rendering halachic decisions.
David -- David rising at
12 o'clock to study Torah.
David -- David, I mean,
studying from Mefiboshes.
It's actually what the Gemara says
in -- what is -- it's taken from
"Tov li toras picha mei'alfei zahav va'chasef."
Why did the Gemara, I mean, portray
David as the great talmid chacham,
the great scholar, the teacher?
Because without it, he wouldn't
have been the great king.
If David was a great king, it’s
only because he was a great teacher.
And his objective was
not politics but scholarship.
Now let me add something else.
Yet, no matter how exalted the idea
of malchus is and exalted it is indeed.
It must -- malchus
-- nevertheless, machlus must be
dovetailed with another idea, namely
that of kedushah, kedushah u'malchus.
Of course, malchus, when realized,
is grand -- is a grand experience.
A closed-up -- what happens
to the malchus if realized?
What happens to the person
who achieves kingship?
A closed-up sensing, self-oriented
-- ego-conscious and within-minded
individual opens up toward the
outside, tears down old fences,
orientations, trends, it'll be a
gesture of magnanimity, spreads out
his arm to embrace Klal Yisrael.
Yet, in spite of the grandeur of
malchus, the realization is not
complete if malchus does not need
kedushah and merge with kedushah.
But what does it mean?
How does malchus merge with kedushah?
We have it in Yishtabach,
kedushah u'malchus.
Where is the link between
malchus and kedushah?
What -- what does the melech have
to do in order to acquire kedushah?
He's already -- he's
aware of his assignment.
He tries to meet the challenge of
history, to answer the summons of
the hour -- of the historical hour.
He opens up his existence.
He tore down old barriers.
He shed his selfishness, his egocentrism.
He understands it.
He understands everybody and
sympathizes with everybody.
He is a teacher, a great teacher.
So what else does he have to do in
order to achieve the pinnacle of malchus?
The apex of malchus, where malchus and
kedushah merge, become one idea.
Which is the ultimate goal of
every Jew, which is the final destiny
-- destination, rather, of every man?
But how -- what -- what is
a melech supposed to do?
Let me try to answer this question.
As we stated before, just a
while ago, Moses was a king.
He was, as I said, the greatest of all
kings because he was the greatest of all
teachers, the greatest of all prophets.
I would like to ask you one question.
When did Moses become a king?
Could you give me the date?
When was the majestic crown
of malchus placed squarely by
the Almighty upon Moses' head?
Of course, the answer is simple;
when he stood before God on
Mount Sinai, not before that.
How do I know it?
How do we know that the crown was
placed upon Moses' head when he stood
before his master on Mount Sinai?
We say it every Shabbos.
"K'lil tiferes v'rosho nasata lo b'omdo
lefanecha al Har Sinai," Moses rejoiced
in the destiny bestowed upon him when
Thou did call him my faithful servant,
placing on his head a crown of glory
as he stood before Thee on Mount Sinai.
It means Moses was crowned
as king on Mount Sinai.
It’s quite logical.
Now, let me ask you another question.
Moses stood before the Almighty, before
the Lord, at the top of the mount, three
times -- at least two times or you could
(inaudible), but at least two times.
When was he -- when was he crowned,
the first time or the last time?
At the time of the first Matan Torah or
at the time of the second Matan Torah?
What do you say?
Correct.
We, of course, we all know the answer.
I wrote "We all know the
answer" before he answered me.
We all know the answer.
He was crowned when he stood before the
-- his master on the Mount Sinai -- on Mount
Sinai for the last time, for the master
God had delivered to him the Shtei Luchos
Avanim, the two tablets of stone, the
so-called Luchot Shniyot, the second ones.
We read just yesterday that before
Moses departed from Har Sinai,
God made Moses' face radiate.
Only then was Moses appointed
and anointed and crowned as king.
By God, by the Almighty.
"And it came to pass," the pasuk
says, "when Moses came down from
the mountain," for the last time,
"that Moses knew not that the skin
of his face sent forth beams."
Again, a third question arises.
Why was he elevated to the stature
of the king only at the time of the
second Matan Torah, using the Jewish
calendar, our calendar, on Yom Kippur?
Why wasn't he elevated to kingdom
on Shavuos, at the time of -- the
first Matan Torah, when he confronted
the Almighty for the first time?
What happened?
During that destiny-charged period,
separating the second Matan Torah
from the first Matan Torah that
promoted Moses to king, to kingdom,
to kingship, what happened?
What event?
You cannot say the confrontation with the
Lord because the confrontation took place
the first time as well as the second time.
There's no reason to consider the
second time superior to the first time.
You certainly know one of these
took place shviras ha'Luchos.
The Luchos were shattered, nothing else.
Shvirat ha'Luchos, the
Luchos were shattered.
The two Tablets of the Testimony,
written with the finger of God, were
broken and shattered in a hurry.
In other words, Moses would have not
attained malchus if the tragedy of
shviras ha'Luchos, the shattering
of the Luchos, had not occurred.
Moses would have been -- if the
tragedy hadn't taken place -- a
great prophet, the greatest of all
teachers, redeemer, but not king.
Kingdom was bestowed upon him after the
first Luchos were -- had been broken.
And God told him to hew two new tablets
of stone from a hard rock and told him
to climb the mount once again in order
to confront his Creator once more.
Why?
What did Moses lack before shviras
ha'Luchos that he had attained after that?
And how did this tragic and heartbreaking
event enhance Moses' personality and
elevated him to the height of majesty?
And I'll tell you what you're
asking and what he gained.
Moses, until the Golden Calf
episode, had never failed.
Never.
He was victorious until that time in all
his undertakings, he was the messenger
of fulfillment, the angel of realization.
His message consisted of the joyous
words, for which the Jews were longing
and yearning and waiting, "Pakod
padadeti es'chem," the double message
of the word, Chazal say, geula kefula.
This message was signed and sealed
by the Shem Havayah, not Kel Shadai.
What does Shem Havayah symbolize?
Fulfillment, realization.
Kel Shin -- Kel Shin-Dalet-Yud
symbolizes promise, waiting, long
waiting, ki ger yehiye zaracha.
Of course, every promise will be
fulfilled, every -- every pledge will
be implemented, but you have to wait.
This was the destiny of Abraham.
Moses' destiny was different.
God revealed Himself with
the medium of Shem Havayah.
Shem Havayah means immediate
victory, immediate realization,
there’s no need to wait.
Shem Havayah means complete -- actually,
complete -- complete victory of
a normal event, over the causal
nexus of a historical event.
He was the message -- he was the
fortunate prophet who brought
with him the message of victory.
He was the prophet when God simply
radiated glory, the prophet of divine
openness and revelation; his authority
was not questioned, nor was it doubted.
"Vayaar Yisrael es ha'yad ha'gedolah
asher asah Adoshem b'Mitzrayim vayiru
ha'am es Adoshem v'yaaminu ba'Adoshem
u'v'Moshe avdo," the pillar of fire,
the pillar of triumph was marching in
front and the pillar of cloud symbolized
protection and safety behind Moses.
Victory and malchus, in the opinion
of Yahadus, are two contradictory,
mutually exclusive concepts.
As long as man is always victorious,
as long as man is always triumphant,
as long as his endeavors are blessed
with success continually, as long as
he continues to search ahead without
being stopped and made to retreat, he
cannot attain malchus together with
kedushah, the highest degree of malchus.
Because malchus, in whose texture
kedushah is interwoven, cannot be
attained if all battles are won, if all
undertakings are -- are realized -- are
carried out, if all promises are
fulfilled and all dreams come true.
The king, in order to attain the pinnacle
of malchus, (inaudible) one must be
crushed, defeated, his aspirations
in shambles, his dreams, visions and
hopes that he suppresses in order to
rise from that invitation and ascend
the throne of majesty and kingship.
Moses could not achieve malchus as long
as his cause to greatness was straight,
without alterations, angles or curves.
As long as there was continuous ascent,
upward movement, aliyah, when all
aspirations were coming true, hope seen
to be in process of realization and
visions appeared to turn into reality,
Moses could not attain the pinnacle of
malchus and Moses couldn't be just a king.
He could be either the greatest of
all kings or he -- or nothing -- and
not to -- or not to be a king at all.
Only when the voice of God, "Lech reid,"
get thee down, "ki shicheis amcha,"
for thy people have dealt corruptly.
Thrust him back from his
heroically conquered, exalted
position and points of vantage.
Only when Moses realized that
he had failed, miserably failed
in -- in the story of Matan Torah.
His people he brought out of Egypt,
shicheis amcha, thy people, not my people,
were not ready for Kabbalas Ha'Torah.
Only then, when he -- in black despair
and desolation, he threw away the
Luchos and broke them, only then, he
was -- only when he was -- only when
he was rejected by God and also -- I
mean, denied, rejected by the people,
only then he was anointed king.
It is God's will.
Why is it so?
It's God's will that man should
not achieve what he is meant
to achieve without being once
defeated -- at least once defeated.
Without failing and losing his very
existential security or without
relapsing to lower levels of being,
without experiencing hester panim, the
hiding of the face, for the mystics
of the Middle Ages used to call, the
lonely dark night of the soul, without
finding himself in front of tightly
closed gates of heaven and just hearing
the echo of one's own voice coming
back from dark, uncharted spaces.
Shviras Ha'Luchos is an integral part
of human destiny.
God decreed man to fail when He addressed
Himself to Adam and told him, "V'kotz
v'dardar tatzmiach lach," thorns and
thistles shall it bring forth to thee,
in the sweat of thy brow shall thou eat
bread 'til thou internment to the ground.
Everybody, great or small,
is subject to God's dictum.
None can escape and none can acquire
greatness, not even Moses, the greatest
and the most glorious of all teachers,
without experiencing defeat and failure.
Yahadus taught man not how -- not only
how to accept failure and not to get
lost, not only how to be defeated and
not to disintegrate, not only how to
be crushed and not to be overcome by
black despair or resignation but also
how to rise after one has been -- has
fallen, how to pick himself up, how
to pick up oneself up without help
after one has been thrown on the top
of the mount into the bottomless abyss.
And Yahadus taught man how to assemble
patiently, the debris of the shattered
Luchos and restore their original
integrity or how to hew new tablets from the
hard rock and how to climb a steep mount,
rising above a black, gaping precipice,
alone, how to replace one's
[inaudible]